على كل اللي ينضم الينا المدون على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وسام قطبي وسامي يسعد
صباحك اهلا بك معنا في الصباح العربيه
وسام سمعنا
صباح الورد
او تقليل استخدامات مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
ممكن الافراط في الاستعمالها بالطريق
الخاطئ يودينا على مناطق مش كويسه مش منيح
يعني كل شيء في العالم اذا بنستعمله زي
العالم والناس اموره
يعني ازاي تاخذ ناقص بشيء خير الامور
اوسطها طيب وسام انا لاحظت انت سامعنا
منيح
اوكي تمام
[ضحك]
ايدك المهم طيب وسام انا لاحظت عليك انه
انت بتنزل كل اسبوع صوره بمعدل يعني مثلا
ب 20 الشهر بتنزل بوسط وبعدين 27 هل هذه
صدفه ولا انت فعلا عندك اسلوب مو منهج انه
انا ببعد اسبوع بخفف من هالكم الهائل من
البستان
ومش هذا الرقم بالتحديد مرات مرات بنزل
مرتين في الاسبوع مرات حتى نوصل للثلاثه
بس اغلب الاوقات صح اللي انت بتحكي انه في
وسط واحد بينزل في الاسبوع بس لانه احنا
متواجدين على اكثر احنا موجودين على التيك
توك وموجودين على انستغرام وموجودين على
اليوتيوب وموجودين على اي تطبيق موجود
حواليكي عم بنحاول نضل نكون اكثر ولكن همم
على الانستغرام خلينا نحكي اكثر انه اه
فعلا احنا بننزل تقرير
سمعتهم من محطه ثانيه ههه
طيب هو كان سؤال واحد او يساوي طيب وسام
همم عن محتواك اكثر يا وسامحكم بحتبك على
مواقع التواصل اللي خلا الناس تتابعك
ومعالجاتك النفسيه في هذا الايطار حدثنا
اكثر
ااا بقدم محتوى مختلف تقريبا على ال ال
التطبيقات المختلفه يعني على الانستغرام
وعلى التيك توك تقريبا بقدم اسكتشات بتحكي
عن الاشياء اللي بتصير معنا بطريقه مختلفه
يعني كل بيت بتصير معنا نفس نفس الجثث
يعني احنا بنتطلع على انه احنا الوحيدين
اللي بيصير معنا هيك بس على همم صوره اكبر
كل العالم بصير معهم نفس الشيء انا باجسد
هاي الصوره بشخصيات معينه عم باعملها وهمم
على اليوتيوب بتلاقيني باعمل اي شيء باحس
همم نفسي اعمل همم
بتلاقيني بعمل بقى عندي خناقه ميوزك
اندرويد
موسيقى وعلى قناه الرئيسيه بتلاقيني بحكي
مع الناس اكثر
وبعمل اشياء همم باستمتع وانا باعملها
يعني هذاك اليوم
ما فيش همم محدد محدد قاعد باعمله
الجو مع الناس اللي بعرفكم وبحبهم طيب
وسام ممكن تتخيل حالك بدون سوشيال ميديا
يوما ما لانه في ناس بتعتبر ان هذا
الموضوع طفره ومش هي المستقبل للتواصل شو
رايك
تقدر تتخلى عن السوشيال ميديا وسام
بقدر اعيش بدون سوشيال ميديا صارت
صارت جزء كبير من حياتي
فما بعرف اذا بقدر اعيش بدون السوشيال
ميديا هسا حتى اذا حطيت تحت الامر الواقع
هضطر اعيش من غير زوجيه بس هل هحب اني
اعيش من غير سوشيال ميديا علما انه الحياه
قاعده عم تتطور وعم بيصير السوشيال ميديا
عم بيصير من من يعني اشي مهم في حياتك كل
شخص زي ال- ال- البياجرا بيتابعه يعني انت
مين حسب السوشيال ميديا بنروح هناك يعني
حساباته
في مده هي كثير حبيت هذا السؤال لانه
كلياتنا بنفوت في دوامه
الاستهلاك المفرط السوشيال ميديا اييه
وما ما ما في مبدع علميه انا بعرفها قد
ايه انت لازم تبعد عن السوشيال ميديا بس
لما بتحس حالك خلص انضغطت ااا او
طبيعي جدا انك تحس هيك انا واحنا في اللا
واعي تبعنا واحنا جدعين عم بنجلد بتلاقينا
عم بنقارن حالنا بافلام
زمان زمان ما كان موجود هذا الحكي لانه
خلاص انت زلمه
بس اليوم لانه الانترنت مسهل لنا الانترنت
مسهل لنا الموضوع
ايه يا ريت الكل يعرف حياته الحقيقيه على
مواقع التواصل شكرا جزيلا لك المدونه على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي شكرا